Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today,
I’m going to explain a science
fiction film called “Last Sunrise.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, a voice narrates
to us about the current condition of the world.
He claims that air-conditioning, oxygen, and
sunrise, are some of the most important things
in the world, but now the world is void of
all of these. The narrator cannot remember
how many days it has been since the sun collapsed,
because it is difficult to tell with no sunrise.
A few years ago, people used all the fossil
fuels, and everyone turned to solar energy
for their basic needs. The narrator laughs at
people who used to say no matter what happens,
the sun will rise tomorrow; because that is not
true anymore. The sun has completely shut down,
and the world has no source of fuel anymore.
Cut to the day it all started; the story takes
place in a futuristic China, where everything
is almost fully powered by solar energy.
A young man named Sun Yang is woken up by a
futuristic AI robot named Ilsa. Yang analyzes the
satellite data from a multi-million dollar company
called Helios. Helios is the manufacturer of solar
power that fuels three-fourths of China. Its CEO
named Wang is the centre of this historical change
and is praised for his accomplishments. Yang
analyzes Helios satellite data, and updates it
on his website. As he does this task, Yang
is bothered to see a nearby star disappear.
He claims that the disappearance of this
star has some effect on the sun itself.
However, the AI robot reminds him that such a
deduction doesn’t follow the law of conservation
of energy, so it is not possible.
When Yang gets out of his apartment,
we see every street and every shop using
solar panels manufactured by Helios.
In the background, the company broadcasts the
development of solar energy in District 4,
the only district left for Helios to
take over. Its logo is everywhere.
The following day, Yang is woken up by an
emergency alarm on his computer. He finds out
that the sun’s luminosity has dropped by fifteen
percent and is continuing to drop quickly. The AI
tells Yang that his assumption about the star was
accurate. Yang quickly tells Ilsa to call Helios
CEO, Wang. Yang asks Wang if he knew that the sun
was going to die today. Wang instead questions him
what he would do if today was the end of the
world. When Yang says he would find a way to
survive, Wang gives him an address and asks him to
come there if he survives today. Yang then barges
into his neighbour’s apartment to get a better
view of the sunrise. As he stands on the windows,
he sees the sun flicker. His neighbour, Chen Mu,
is confused as to why he is here and asks him to
go away, but Yang doesn’t even blink his eyes as
he watches the sun die. TVs start to broadcast
the event unfold, and reports of a flickering
moon from the other side of the world are heard.
Suddenly the flickering starts getting violent
and everything goes dark within seconds.
Yang goes back to his room as Chen Mu
follows him, asking what is going on.
He ignores her and asks Ilsa what is going to
happen now. Ilsa informs him that the temperature
is going to drop to 0 Fahrenheit in a week and
-100 Fahrenheit in a year, oxygen will slowly
deplete, all forms of life will disappear
and the Earth will become a frozen planet.
Yang asks Chen Mu to leave the city, and goes out
himself. People are confused and panicking. The
grocery store is full of people trying to stock up
supplies, but the cashier cannot check out because
of lack of power. The lights are still working,
but they will be out in twenty-four hours.
Yang takes a bottle of water and a map to help him
find the location Wang had told him about. On his
way out, he is walking through a dark alley, and
a mugger hits him unconscious and injures his leg.
He then takes his money. When he opens his
eyes again, Ilsa announces to him that he has
slept for twelve hours and eighteen minutes.
He rushes back to his apartment, and packs his
clothes and some instant noodles. Chen Mu is at
his door with her backpack, asking for his help to
call her parents. Yang tells her there is no way
he can help her and asks her to go away. However,
when she mentions owning a car, the two decide
to travel together. Before starting the journey,
Chen Mu makes Yang promise that he will take her
to her parent’s house after they visit CEO Wang.
The two then leave for the place and
encounter a large traffic jam on the way.
Chen Mu gets out of the car to go to the washroom,
and Yang takes this opportunity to drive away, but
is stopped by a crowd. When she is back, she asks
her why he is not in the place they parked, and he
lies, saying that he was making a U-turn. The two
finally reach Wang’s home at night, and meet other
people who happened to be stranded there.
They drink around the fire, while a socially
anxious Yang stays in a corner. Later, his watch
runs out of battery and Ilsa stops talking to him.
The death of the AI robot saddens Yang, as she was
his only friend. Chen Mu notices this and tries to
comfort him. The two talk and bond. Later when
they wake up, Yang asks Wang what his plan is.
Since Wang is a billionaire, Yang believes that he
has a way to survive. To his distress, Wang claims
that this situation is beyond repair, he wants to
stay in the place until death comes. According to
Wang, a highly advanced civilization from far
in space is harvesting energy from other stars,
and simultaneously terminating life on other
planets. This time, the earth is their target
and they have been successful. A wormhole has
been created in the center of the solar system,
and with the lack of gravity, all the planets will
soon fly away from the system including the earth.
In the end, Wang gives Yang the
coordinates of a location of district four,
and tells him he should go there
if he really wants to survive.
When Chen Mu wakes up, the two continue their
journey. The temperature has fallen exponentially
so much that Yang’s bottle of water freezes.
Chen Mu notices a space shuttle taking off, and
Yang comments that it might be rich people trying
to fly away to another planet to stay alive. He
drives Chen Mu to her parents’ home as promised,
and continues his journey to the place Wang told
him about. However, he notices Chen Mu had left
her plant in her car and goes back to return it.
When he gets there, he finds a distressed Chen
Mu alone in the house, she doesn’t speak a word,
unlike her usual talkative self. All of the people
of the town had left in the time of emergency.
We see the fish aquarium in the house is freezing.
Yang goes inside a room, and is horrified to see
both her parents dead in the bed. He takes a
letter from her father’s hand, and brings it back
to Chen Mu. It turns out that they were preparing
for Chen Mu’s arrival before the death of the sun.
As they wrote her the letter asking her
to take care of herself in the city,
a group of thugs entered the house and killed
both of them. Chen Mu breaks down crying,
when Yang tells her that he too is an orphan and
doesn’t know who his parents are. He asks her to
come with him to district 4, the place Wang told
him about. The two then continue their journey.
After a while, they reach district 3 and are
surprised how the map brought them the wrong way.
Their car’s battery is dying, so they go a little
forward, and see a house selling electricity. When
they go in, an old couple welcomes them and claims
they have electricity that they extract from coal.
However, the woman then locks Chen Mu inside the
washroom and snatches the car keys from Yang.
They apologize as they take the car and drive
away. Chen Mu and Yang are in distress. They
are close to district four, but Yang’s leg injury
from the time the thug hit him is getting worse.
He tells Chen Mu to go there alone, but she
insists she won’t leave without Yang. After much
thinking, they make their way to district four on
foot. On their way, they rest for a while feeding
on instant noodles and watching the beautiful
and cruel night sky. Without the sunlight,
it looks astonishingly beautiful. When they
reach the city area again, they find their car
deserted by the side of the road. But just then,
a group of mineworkers comes looking for them.
To save Chen Mu, Yang turns himself in. They
take him to their headquarters and keep him as
one of the mineworkers to extract coal. Chen Mu
however doesn’t give up and goes to rescue Yang
with just a pepper spray. She manages to free him
from the place, but Yang gets shot in the process.
When they are back in the car, Chen Mu drives
to district 4 at full speed, hoping to save
Yang. They stop at district 4’s entrance, and Yang
realizes that the place has geothermal energy that
can save them. They continue their journey and see
the car’s windows and the road starting to freeze.
They do not have a lot of time, but just
then their car runs out of battery and stops.
With no way out, the two stay together on
the back seat, holding each other’s hand.
An automated voice from the car says that the two
are experiencing their last moments on the earth.
After a while, Chen Mu calls
Yang’s name but he doesn’t answer.
Crying, she places her head on his shoulder
and falls asleep while freezing.
Sometime later, a car stops beside theirs. A
couple comes out of it and brings unconscious
Yang and Chen Mu with them. They drive
the two to a safe place in district 4.
In the end, a voice in the background narrates
that the earth is moving at high speed
into another galaxy. Soon, they will reach
their new home which has three suns.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on notifications,
and leave a like to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching